Isn't there a kind of temptation in the hijab,
our sister in God? No
Arabic Islam
[Music]
Isn't there
a kind of temptation in the hijab, our
sister in God? Let not the devil
tempt you. The hijab is an obligation from our gracious Lord. We heard our sister, Qulajab,
saying something that is not pleasing about the hijab. They said: Dark darkness.
Between the clothes, they said: tents hung over the
necks.
They called for the liberation of the girl, and they wrote in it the book,
and they laid out a path of finery that the youth will not waste. Oh, our sister,
this is the howl of the haters from the wolves
if they strike. And the oppressors will have punishment. And God will reveal
their injustice on the Day of Judgment, and Paradise is their refuge. Good
Quran
[Music]